Joe Biden's National Park Service
recently proposed removing the William
Penn statue from a park in Philadelphia
William pen you may have guessed from
the name or if you know anything about
American history you already know this
is the founder of the state of
Pennsylvania deep into the Pennsylvania
Wilderness and Biden wanted his memorial
gone this comes just a few weeks after
the Biden Administration ordered that a
century old memorial to post-war
reconciliation had to be torn down in
Arlington National Cemetery in the case
of the Penn statue they wanted to
replace it want to take it down and
replace it with uh something else that
would honor Native Americans